your brothers and sisters in the slum
net from Norway are establishing a
Masjid a dawah center this Center this
Masjid this educational institution will
act like a beacon of light calling the
Muslims in Norway back to the essence of
Islam so give generously and Allah
azzawajal will give you even I wanted to
ask you now because this is the Hot
Topic especially in the Muslim Community
about your conversion yeah so tell us
the story like what happened exactly
well I think a lot of people have been
following me for a while understand that
I've been very respectful of Islam for a
long time I was born in a Christian
country I was raised as a Christian and
I've always been very respectful of
Islam and it's become more and more
obvious to me and and more and more
pertinent that Islam is the last
religion on the planet when I talk about
Islam because I'm new to it yeah I I'm a
little bit careful right because I'm new
to it I'm certainly not a scholar
there's so much I need to learn I know
I'm on a Learning Journey I'm not here
to sit here and talk scripture I don't
know those things yet I'm here to learn
but we're here at your assistance thank
you brother thank you thank you but um
it's just for me it feels like the last
religion on Earth I feel like there's no
other religion people say to me why did
you convert and I said I don't really
feel it as a conversion I it's almost
like I knew Gog was real and now I've
become religious and they say oh you're
religious before I was like religious
before how Christian what does Christian
mean like who's not a Christian you go
to Christian nations and everyone says
they're a Christian look how they live
their lives go into the average church
is anyone actually fearful of God
anybody no the girls are out on Saturday
night drinking and they turn up to
church because their parents made them
but there's there's no substance to the
religion and also
Islam very closely reflects my personal
beliefs I through my personal life I've
learned that if you don't have standards
and you're not a strong person who's
prepared to defend his ideas you will be
crushed yes and we look at most
religions in the world today which are
not prepared to defend their ideas
what's happened to them they're just
getting crushed and now we have
Christianity as an idea which is
basically said well we can't set any
firm rules because everyone will just
quit so instead let's make it so easy to
be a Christian that nobody has to put
any effort in and then accept everybody
no matter what and hopefully we can keep
the church doors open that's not that's
not God to me you know God to me is is
strong God to me is something to be
feared God to me something someone that
people are afraid to mock yeah God to me
is someone that you have to go out of
your way to prove something to God to me
has red lines like God to me represents
the Islamic faith the Christian God to
me I don't see God I can't explain I
don't see anything there so to me it was
it was the only logical choice in the
end I mean many as you're saying this
I'm sure many people are like ecstatic
and extremely happy it's a great it's a
great thing for everyone honestly
because you know just anyone coming into
Islam is is you know the prophet is
better than the world and everything in
it yeah but imagine now somebody of
major influence I mean you're the most
Googled person on the planet I'm not
sure if you're still yeah I think Putin
might have beat me as of last week but I
think it's between me and Putin at the
moment but I don't want to lose to Putin
look Putin's the Big G I don't want more
enemies like it's fine Vladimir you can
have it I never thought I'd hear you
saying that statement yeah put wouldn't
beat me last year right yeah I think
we're just something the most Google but
no no it's definitely something
beautiful and a lot of people have you
know you'll be surprised at how many
women as well like because obviously the
the accusations of misogynist you know
but but a lot of women handle Allah
especially in the Muslim World they
absolutely happy in fact let me tell you
a story just before I came here today
one um one particular woman I can't
remember her identity but she's working
as a school teacher yep in London and
actually my friend told me that she was
kicked out of school because they had
this campaign against you in the schools
I'm not sure if you're aware of it yeah
this was part of the cancellation I
didn't know about this yeah so in in
British schools they said you know if
you say anything good about if you if
you say anything good about this person
or you have to be reported or prevented
and if you say anything you know you
have to kind of combat his extremism or
whatever it may be right so she because
when you became Muslim she abstained
from doing that she said I can't really
do that because you know Islamic clause
and it's it's backbiting and he's got
honor and Islam and so on and
unfortunately they fired her from that
from the position wow so you can see
that this is the level of encroachment
we're talking about here so and this
shows you that the level of fraternity
that exists and not only the fact that
you know when you're looking at Old
Twitter or whatever Twitter or whatever
social media it's not a representation
of what's really happening of course of
course and I I mean that's that's crazy
to hear and what's most crazy is
yeah the the fervor behind this idea
that I'm somehow extremist is truly it's
truly clown world like I've sat as a
professional and and analyzed my content
and understood which things can be taken
out of context and which things were
said in a way perhaps they wouldn't
shouldn't have been said before I was
massively famous but we have to sit here
and understand that if you take anybody
on the planet and give them seven years
of YouTube and then they decide and they
blow up big you're gonna be able to find
30 to 45 seconds of clip across all
those years that could be taken out of
context right yeah and and and and it's
truly crazy because they sit and say oh
yeah but you know the young boys are
watching your stuff and they don't truly
understand all of it and it there's
Nuance that's missing and my argument is
very simple my argument is well one
you're taking small Clips out of context
and two there's not a single piece of
content on the internet that 14 year old
boy can't misunderstand name somebody
name someone who's producing content on
the internet that you would be 100 happy
for a 14 year old drill artists and so
they say that I mean I live in an area
this I'm not going to mention the names
of the artist but they're talking about
going to this person's house and killing
it and killing him in the middle of a
life crime epidemic yeah we have little
Nas twerking on having sex with level in
his music videos like we're gonna sit
here and talk about how children can be
impressionable young children and I'm
sitting there saying there's no way I'm
the worst person that's not why they're
deleting me the difference for them is
as you've mentioned on those on those
fronts it doesn't matter to them because
it's like okay they're consuming our
hedonistic products or whatever it is
that doesn't change their world view
whereas what you're saying is
ideological now you're you're
challenging the status quo of the LW of
the liberal world order your challenging
second wave feministic Notions you are
challenging some liberal Notions you're
challenging ideas commonplace ideas of
of Tolerance and George Orwell said it
very well he said that the more a
society moves away from the truth the
more it hates people who speak it
absolutely and and you're and you're
right and I think even the basic things
I teach because some people have said to
me Andrew all you teach about is
personal responsibility motivation
working hard getting up and doing the
right thing I said that's the absolute
those are the things they're most afraid
of if you teach people to have standards
for themselves and to be morally really
strong people and to know right from
wrong then they can't brainwash you so
that's what they're most afraid of
they're most afraid of young men who men
looking up and going no no I don't
believe that
no I don't believe it I don't want to
and I want to go do this I want to go to
the gym and be strong or I want to
believe X or I want to be a moral person
they genuinely have a problem with
Baseline morality yes you understand
when some people recognize when I
convert to Islam that there was a time I
was an atheist there was a time when I
was atheistic and the reason I am now so
absolutely certain that God is real is
because I've seen evil I've seen shaytan
I've seen it when you see enough evil
you realize that there must be an equal
and opposite force and there are people
out there in the world today doing the
work of the devil genuine demons who are
trying to destroy the Baseline morality
that's inside of all of us we're all
born with some kind of morality and
they're trying to destroy it and that's
exactly the Islamic understanding that
we believe that you're born with
something called fitra which is the
initial goodness you're born with an
innate belief receptivity to believe in
one God and then that is corrupted in
fact there's a prophet Hadith of the
Prophet where he says
every born child is born upon this
initial goodness
and then his father and mother or his
parents they socialize him into you know
Christianity Judas and magism so the
idea is that everyone is born with this
initial uh goodness and this initial uh
will or want to believe in God one God
and then as you mentioned I mean it's
what you're mentioning here is really is
profound because you're you're
mentioning a central Doctrine in Islam
but but it's and and this is why perhaps
I found God the way I did because I
understood all these things first and
then I saw the Quran and confirmed so
many things for me you know like even
the conversations I've been having so
far so many things have been confirmed
and it's amazing the knowledge that's
inside of it which is so applicable
today yeah for for a old book right you
know it's supposed to be old but it
seems so so Timeless but it's truly
amazing but you're you're totally right
and and the Baseline morality I don't
think most people understand that when
they're doing this under the guise of
Tolerance when they're saying be so
tolerant that you no longer believe in
right from wrong they're not doing doing
that to make Society a better place
they're doing that to empty your brain
so that you have no resistance to the
slave mind programming they want to get
you to a point where if they tell you
the sky is green yeah you look at with
your own eyes yeah and you see blue but
no the sky is green that's what they
want so that you have to have nothing in
your brain that can prevent that if you
have God if you have no I believe this
is right and wrong if you have personal
responsibility if you have
self-accountability if you're a person
who sticks up for what he believes all
that's bad to them they want all of that
gone so they could tell you the sky is
green and and I don't want to say too
much because I don't want the stream to
end but they're going to tell you
something much worse than the sky is
green they're going to tell you
something else and and if they're trying
to program us all into slaves I remember
when I was in my undergraduate days and
I was reading a particular book by this
guy called Jeremy Bentham who became
like you know the spiritual forefather
of Jose Mill who is the father of like
social liberalism of today and I
remember reading this because it was so
powerful because it linked to something
I read in the Quran he said that you
know you have two gods he said you have
the god of pain and you have the God of
Pleasure and I thought this is so
interesting the Quran States you know
have you seen the one who takes his own
desires as a God and because now there
is no transcendental force that we can
look up and as you say venerate now
we're forced to be slaves to the system
yeah we're to our own desires or I mean
the Quran has another verse which I
think is so powerful and it connects
very well with what you're saying
that God has struck a parable of a man
that he's got many different slave
owners
and another kind of man who's only got
one slave owner he's God is basically
telling us in the Quran that you've got
one example of one individual who's got
multiple slave owners and another one
with just one he says
are they the same
so here the idea is
as Rousseau said that his liberal
philosophy said that man is Born Free
but everywhere in Chains
this is the order because if you don't
have that God to to worship then you're
going to end up having to worship to
everything else and the whole part of
the shahada which you took which is
the the true meaning of that is that
there is no God worthy of worship except
for one God which means that your your
desires or the system or these people
that want to control us they are the
problem is they're not worthy of worship
the only one worthy of our subordination
and submission is the creator of the
heavens and the Earth there's no one
else I agree and it's it's it's I
completely agree and I've agreed with
this for the longest time you know I've
never been to like a music concert and
people ask me why and I said I just look
at it and I feel embarrassed I look at
someone up on a stage dancing around and
I look at hundreds of thousands of
peasants in the crowd just yeah yeah
yeah I'm like it's embarrass I feel
cringe it's like secondhand
embarrassment when I see these festivals
and everyone's losing their our mind or
these music concerts I genuinely feel
embarrassed for the people who go
because to me that is a form of worship
like yeah you can listen to the music at
home for free you're like you don't have
to wait in that line and stand out in
the cold like I don't know perhaps it
was a bit extreme but I've always known
that they're trying to give us false
Idols to some degree and when I speak to
atheists atheists say oh I don't believe
in God but they they've signed up so
hard to the liberal woke agenda they're
as religious as anybody but they're just
believing in the wrong things they're
believing in degeneracy and they're
believing in the work of the devil so
humans always need something to believe
in and it's a great thing you said about
your own desires it's like
one one guy I was talking to since my
conversion says it's interesting that
somebody with everything all the Western
World yeah I think everything somebody
could want exactly has now converted and
I said yeah because even before my
conversion I understood that Hedonism is
a black hole and you can never fill it
you're never going to be able to have
enough girls to be happy with girls
you're never gonna be able to have
enough money to be happy with money you
know be able to you know drink enough to
be happy with drinking like it's a black
hole and you can pour endless things
down it but you'll never fill it up and
you need to have some degree of
self-restraint and I've always been a
very disciplined person I've never made
mistakes but certainly yeah the higher
power is is going to give you more
satisfaction in your heart than endless
endless insanity